final details revealed today in the
death of the man who killed trooper
micah may during a pursuit on i-15 last
july a fact-finding review held this
morning regarding 60-year-old douglas
claiborne as joe moeller reports it was
explained why law enforcement had no
choice but to shoot him during the
confrontation
the person was described as being
distraught and holding a butcher style
knife in their hand investigators say it
all started with a carjacking they broke
down why douglas claiborne was shot and
killed the decedent did not stop for the
troopers and they initiated vehicle
pursuit the pursuit went on for 42
minutes this is video from metro's
helicopter
it shows the moment trooper micah may
was hit and when troopers did a pit
maneuver before opening fire this is
from a patrol car it shows trooper may
running right before he got hit trooper
micah may attempted to set up stop
sticks on i-15 southbound investigators
say four law enforcement officers opened
fire on claiborne the officers during
their statements
two of them commented specifically that
they could see the suspect grabbing for
trooper may's weapon a toxicology report
revealed a large amount of meth in
claiborne's system in this particular
instance the decedent's levels of
methamphetamine being 9 000 nanograms
per milliliter it's fair to say that's
extremely high that's extremely high may
died two days later after being hit
investigators say they don't know if
claiborne intentionally hit may or not
the hearing ended with written public
questions did the trooper who was struck
by the suspect violates safety protocol
by crossing multiple lanes of traffic
exposing himself from a protected
position in order to deploy stop sticks
i can't speak to nhp's training or
policies on what or would not be
considered violation of safety protocols
joe muller live local now